so did the movie come out yet is the
movie ever going to come out I feel like
it will it should I think they're not
going to scrap it cuz it's too much PR
or something or too much B PR so they
get rid of Batgirl but they're not going
no it's going to be a double feature the
two of them back to
[Music]
back our boy Alec Baldwin's back in the
news was he did he go to jail no no but
he's being hit with a new criminal
charge in the rust case which is
basically the the same charge that he
had already been hit wait who's this guy
again he sounds so familiar guess just
guess just guess I uh is he like a
podcaster billy Baldwin think Baldwin
Pianos think about that oh I have one
dude it's that guy yeah yeah Roll It Out
roll out the p is he the guy that shot
at the yes yes at the cameraman uh yeah
the camera woman he shot a
lady yeah he surprised about like
someone has to stop him it makes it
worse when you shoot a lady yeah you
can't shoot no lady cuz you know girls
be dying all gay and stuff they'll be
like you know guys die like slow motion
and if it's an Indian dude it's dramatic
as [__] they'll be like oh no and then
they have like a huge ass memory
flashback and it's their life and then
they come back and then they go oh and
then a huge Ensemble comes out and
dances
celebration
and then somehow like the bullet goes
out of their body or they've been
wearing a necklace and it got stopped or
something magical happen I don't think
that's what happened for this though
yeah no I think she just died yeah hard
to ruin it
fortunately a girl I wish she had like a
Bible in her in her shirt pocket or like
Flanders so Alec Baldwin of Baldwin
Pianos uh got hit with a new grand jury
indictment out of Santa Fe and it says
he's being rung up on one count of inv
voluntary manslaughter involving
negligent use of a firearm okay however
there's an alternative charge you could
face which is involuntary manslaughter
without due caution or circumspection
huh sounds like the same exact thing
speak English so so there's te
technically two charges listed uh and
the grand jury agreed that there was
enough evidence to be prosecuted for
that for him to be prosecuted on either
or but the DA's office will presumably
only pursue one of them so Alec had
already been put through this entire
thing and was uh charged with
involuntary manslaughter but those
charges were eventually dropped so he
basically is just kind of getting rebr
into that with another indictment of the
similar similar type of thing and he's
going back through the the entire thing
again damn is this happening in
California it was out of Santa Fe uh so
that could be where was the first meico
cuz I was like man if it's California
it's cool Alec just go to jail you'll be
out in 48 hours bro yeah what you stop
by Target and steal steal a couple
things and then they'll just let you out
it's no big deal but oh man did they
finish all the they finished all the
civil cases over this uh I believe he
only went through that first indictment
where he pleed not guilty and he's
probably going to plead that
again uh but probably had to settle just
pay a bunch of money the family to
Hutchins to helina Hutchins who is a
woman and how do it's Indian guy it's
Indian guy oh Indian yeah it's Indian
guy
that was good yeah so did the movie come
out yet is the movie ever going to come
out I feel like it will it should I
think they're not going to scrap it cuz
it's too much PR or something or too
much bad PR so they get rid of Batgirl
but they're not going no it's going to
be a double feature the two of them back
to
back well they made the crow after yeah
after Jason Lee died people like Brandon
Le died Brandon Lee people like that
movie damn no the conspiracy is like
like they were trying to kill him to
stop the lead line it says that
obviously the the shooting uh sometimes
I go into the deep dark of the Asian
incel world and um they have some really
cool theories one of them is that they
didn't want to see a Asian man win so
[__] big Hollywood wanted to kill
this guy cuz they were they were scared
that all of a sudden they'll be a craze
of Asian men on film and all the
beautiful white women of the world will
go toward Asian men and they they feared
that so I was like that's a [__]
hilarious Theory but that's that was one
of their incels got crazy theories they
seem untested they seem like they're not
no one else like challenges their
thoughts on I mean it's a circle
jerk production is basically uh
scheduled to resume in 2023 um with the
same people in the same cast and the
same camera they were re no because the
camera lady died but her husband is an
EP now on it oh right yeah he got
credits how convenient yeah that that
was a part of the set I guess um
apparently there was mixed um reviews
and reactions towards the news from
certain people that were working on the
project so some people didn't come back
because they didn't believe that the
project should continue um some people
on the cast were
replaced uh and then what's his face uh
Al Baldwin of Baldwin Pianos came back
of Baldwin Park returned to the set to
finish filming a oh yeah also of Baldwin
Park to finish Baldwin is a famous
family name in Hawaii
cool yeah oh it does say that of a
really cool famous family name in Hawaii
it is there's a street Alexander
Baldwin sick are there any others yeah
one are their famous Baldwins you know
any other you know any Baldwin in I
don't know any Baldwins but always
conspiracy hat every time I hear any
story it's like all right what was he
going to start talking about like why do
you cancel him again you already
canceled him once you let him go and
then why do you move the machine to like
publicly cancel him again and it's
usually all right he was either going to
start talking he was going to talk about
what happened he was going to say
something he didn't want to say and you
move the entire Justice machine to
cancel him again in public ey who who
would be motivated to do something like
that I don't know cuz cuz his husband
her husband already is an EP so it's not
like he can need more Justice in a
certain way right I mean he was a part
of kind of the Hollywood establishment
for a long time he was a high ranking
dude in that yeah and then all of a
sudden they're coming after him like why
that's weird maybe he's going to finally
expose the kid touch and stuff that
Hollywood does do you think it was kid-
touching related that's what Joe's
asking I mean that's usually the case
right Hollywood you think this is linked
to that baldman family in Hawaii I don't
Alexander Baldwin they love Shirley
temples at Hollywood I'm telling you
that man's Temple it's not a bage it's a
little girl oh not the drink I thought
it was a seven up with the Cherry yeah
with cherries yeah but the original is
that little girl that that danced and
stuff oh I
see the redhead didn't mean it what do
you mean nothing the stuff that Anthony
knows is foul man that's only because I
got my conspiracy hat that he gave me no
but Anthony goes cuz you're in the inner
walls he's so conspiracy that conspiracy
theorist look at him and go he crazy you
want to know a conspiracy theory I think
that they released these double Flame
Hot Cheetos and then over time made them
just like the regular flaming hot are
they really double hot that's what I'm
saying they're not even they're not even
close to what the OG double Mar that's
just good marketing yeah dude they
should be twice as red they should watch
eat it it's going to be exactly like the
red this looks exactly the
same what is what is that though is that
would it burn your guts these used to be
way more hot that's not even that
doesn't look like like flaming
hot I know diversion right it doesn't
look it doesn't taste twice as hot
[__] conspiracies everywhere and
that's all I got a good conspiracy for
you we're going to talk about that in
another video but yes let's her husband
is still executive executive producer
right yes this [__] was a planned he
planned he planned it he wanted her gone
yeah and was able to get Alec Baldwin of
Baldwin Piano Baldwin Park and Hawaii to
agree to be the guy who's [__] put on
the ringer for this that's a they got to
be good friends no cuz he has something
on him that's why surely
temples this is all starting to make
sense now yeah everything comes full
circle I think it's making less sense I
don't even know what you guys talking
about anymore yeah don't worry about it
they should just get rid of this [__]
movie huh they should just not do this
movie anymore I want to watch it even
more now yeah what if it sucks but it's
kind of like a level of marke suppos be
a [__] cowboy movie yeah what if that
is part of it because if the thing is
done and there's no more trials and it's
all over doesn't the promo sort of end
for the movie oh yeah don't they have to
keep people on the edge about it maybe
they'll they'll re-release this so they
could uh have the trailer out tomorrow
yeah you're saying they just finished
production so they're like how do we
Market this [__] strikes over one more
time you just keep it on the headlines
right you can't just keep saying oh the
movie's coming out movies coming maybe
they're inditing him just so that they
can get the headlines get everyone
talking about it thinking about it so
when they do cuz and then he goes to
jail in California they release the
movie It's popular he gets released in
448 and he's at the premere and then
they got box office sales up the wues
cuz everyone's going to watch the movie
like where's the moment that he killed
that guy right everyone's going to be
looking for that exact moment fu yeah
and that's crazy huh that people are
going to be want to watch it you think
they would leave it in you think they
would leave that in yeah for sure it's
when the camera probably Jitters a
little I feel like they oh my I mean
they won't leave like maybe not that
that exact moment on film but the moment
where it happens in the movie did they
did they leave it in there for uh
Brandon Lee yeah yeah for some reason I
only see the game of death in my head
right now but yes Kareem nope the only
thing I remember is the Crow If you were
the filmmaker of Russ would you leave
that scene in oh yeah you would have to
right you have to that's art it's
provocative well if you're now the EP
who has a final say in most films then
no one can argue with him for leaving it
in cuz that was his wife that's true
even though he got paid for it probably
EP by like title I don't think they're
like actually letting him make
decisions but then he's the scapegoat
now if like oh you don't like that it's
in there well talk to her husband you
should have said something yeah you
should have said something I know whose
voice that is what a [__] situation
yeah it's pretty weird but it is true
that it seems like why would that be
news that he's going back for the same
thing unless they had some kind of
vehicle for it they're just trying to
promote the movie marketing is so crazy
nowadays huh yep I just wish that at the
end of the day she's not even dead and
they're all just like hey how's that for
marketing but not the world we live in
no no [__]
[Music]
way